hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video we're back on foreigner again and
today was actually going to be something
about the road map and what to expect
for the month of May I was gonna do that
last week but as the road map came out a
day before I was going to upload the
video I decided to let's switch this up
and instead of talking about the road
map for this month let's talk about year
four season two and what I personally
want within that season it's going to
include things like changes to the
Battle pass execution ideas armor new
characters and stuff like that so as
long as like to be if you do enjoy
subscribe before new I cover the
informational side a foreigner that
being the balance changes the here
updates the patch notes in the leaks if
you're gonna be kept up to date with
everything happening within the world of
foreigner and never miss out on an
update at least a subscribe to the
channel but that let's get started with
today's video so first up is armor it's
kind of been confirmed that armor will
be coming this season although we don't
know for what the characters are gonna
be or what the style is going to be that
will be coming in season two year four
but no matter what though the DLC one
characters being gladiator Centurion
Highlanders shaman are a Musha and
shinobi need new original armor now some
variations actual new armor I think the
last time that they got real new armor
was season five although I think some of
them could be considered variants but
that's what I'm gonna go off of because
I know that in season eight they did get
armor but that was definitely confirmed
to be a variants of current armor they
already had in the game but you get the
point it's been a very very long time
since some of these characters have had
some armor honestly I don't play a lot
of the DLC one characters but I would
say Highlander having pants would be
pretty interesting to see not sure how
the Highlander maids would like that
though as obviously he only has kilts I
think it's pretty nice to have a switch
up in my opinion and obviously if you
don't like the pants there's like a
dozen options of kills who can choose
for him so you're really not losing too
much there obviously the addition of
mask or maskless armor would be dope to
having a mask for shaman or Highlander
will be kind of cool or having no helmet
at all for Centurion or gladiator would
be cool too I know so people are against
it as they like to kind of immerse
themselves within the character and
seeing the face of the character kind of
ruins that immersion but I've never
really felt that way with any of my
characters so this wouldn't concern me
I'm also just extremely curious what the
face models that you be would put in the
game would be
next up is executions as you know we get
executions every season so I don't doubt
this will be a thing but I wanted to
touch on this as they did it once and it
was game-changing they need to do
another round of feet executions the
feet executions was something that was
just really interesting and we've had
loads of executions and they're all
really nice but they really did switch
it up when they started using these
equipment from all the feats as a whole
season of executions and they were
really really well done and they can
100% do a ton of things with these feats
as well for example most of the bomb
ones currently were just throwing the
bomb and blowing it up but there could
be many differences with this like maybe
lighting the bomb and then throwing it
it knocks out the opponent kind of like
warden's execution but then it never
blows up and the character just kind of
waits to see what happens and then moves
on with their day or they light the fuse
they throw it at the opponent nothing
happens and then the opponent picks it
up to inspect what happened and then it
blows up as the explosion was a little
bit delayed and they die just kind of
some stuff I thought would be pretty
cool for some executions as I extremely
enjoyed those feet executions and I
would love to see more because there's a
lot of different unique things you could
do with these next up but probably the
longest topic that we have so far is the
battle pass I would 100% want there to
be one I'm about 99% sure that they're
gonna be adding one I don't see why they
wouldn't what regardless won the battle
pass gets added they got to switch them
things up they're gonna move all the
steel the salvage the scavenger crates
the XP tickets and the champion status
into the free version of the pass these
are all things all players earned while
playing so this should be in the free
pass as they're already getting that
stuff free already and leave everything
else in the paid past such as outfits
ornaments executions etc since they're
considered paid content and you have to
pay for those in the menus for each hero
so paid content should be in the paid
section and organized as well and makes
a whole lot of sense the only thing
that's a little bit fishy is the weapons
and if they eventually add armor to the
pass as well it's a solid selling point
from a marketing perspective but I note
that the community is very divided on
this issue I've down to have it in the
past though as at least from my
perspective I'm gonna be purchasing
every pass any way that they come out
with so it doesn't really matter if it's
in the free or the paid version as I'm
going to be getting it anyway but of
course not everybody is in the same
situation as me not everyone is going to
buy the past I never one has
money too so like I said just from my
perspective it wouldn't really matter if
it's in the free or paid version for the
weapons or if it's not even in the past
at all they should also definitely raise
the amount of free content now not
adding more as we had just discussed
that but I mean adding more in terms of
like a quantity you know 300 steel 100
Salvage and a scavenger crate that's not
enough there needs to be a hell of a lot
more than that I could get a hundred
Salvage by playing one game so why
should I spend more time and grind more
for a similar reward that could take 10
to 15 minutes if that to get increasing
the numbers would make it worth it and
adding more to the free pass for the
players who can purchase the paid
version would give them something to
grind to in the paid version I'd
actually really like where the sit these
signatures any executions are so I'm
totally cool with that but this is
something that I take into account with
a lot of games that have battle passes
and it's about making the content worth
it putting the executions in the very
last places of the pass makes perfect
sense
putting an effect in tier 4 9 14 and 19
with the only difference being the
faction that gets it makes no sense to
me
I understand they need to fill the
spaces in the past and that's totally
fine but what's more annoying than that
is that the execution effect for the
current battle pass is within the first
four tiers I mean you get it at tier
four with the first one for the idol
effect being at tier 54 why is it the
same effect different version but a 50
tier difference which that makes
absolutely no sense and there's no
difference for why it's being put up so
high putting executions at tier 96 to
100 makes sense as it's rare content
it's the most exciting part of the pass
and it's something worth the 100 tier
grind if we try to fit this same formula
with keeping the effect in mind it
doesn't make any sense whatsoever lastly
on the past is they got to extend it
this can either be done by increasing
the original number from 100 to say 150
or by adding stuff after tier 100 I'm
leading more toward adding things after
100 as I know some players don't have
the time to make it to that highest rank
I've achieved rank 100 in the in the
battle pass extremely quickly and
probably plenty of you have to as it
only takes 300 points per rank and
that's like a decent game of breach two
times and you're good and even if you
have especially if you have the dailies
that's like one or two games still a
breach and you're
in one or two levels in a very quick
amount of time and it doesn't take that
long
so making content after tier 100 is
worth it for those players who get there
quickly there'd be stuff in there from
the free pass as adding more weapons and
outfits after 100 makes no sense and
that's just the same thing as making the
pass longer doesn't really make any
sense to do that
adding steel scavenger crates XP tickets
etc would fit and would probably be more
than the original so if we take into an
example of the way that I wanted the
pass to be made we would have stuff at
the first tiers of the 100 and the free
pass being yo three tickets 700 steel
500 salvaged etc that could be within
the first 100 tiers within the free pass
well after 100 could be double bet as to
make it worth it going that extra length
to get there for the paid version it
could be like every five or so levels as
obviously this is still a business form
Ubisoft's perspective and it probably
would not be in their best interest to
make this content every single level as
no one would really need the buy for
steel or anything like that and if they
wanted to add something to the free
version they could make it every 5 for
the paid and every 10 for the free
version so you're getting a lot more if
you have the paid version but you're
still getting stuff even if you have the
free version there's an image on the
screen that makes sense it makes sense
in my head that's why I wanted to show
it on screen of kind of what I'm
thinking and then lastly I wanted to
talk about a new character and of course
a new character will be released and
personally without taking into account
movesets armor anything like that just
strictly a idea I would probably pick a
Mongolian warrior I think having a
Mongolian warrior in the game would be
nice and addition to the cast and I'm
honestly not sure where they would
belong I would think maybe the woollen
as I did a little quick searches on some
of the history of the Mongolian Warriors
and it seems like they resided at the
time in China although this could be
totally wrong of course I've stated in
many videos I'm not a historian so this
could easily be completely wrong as for
character balance I think a Centurion
rework is obviously needed need i say
more for that besides him i'd say
shinobi needs a huge overall of his kit
as he's pretty weak in the game
currently and attacking from long range
never really made sense to me within the
confines of this game so I really think
that needs a whole change I'm also
getting really sick of getting G bead
off-screen from that long range version
but
as always I'm not a pro and I don't
really know everything there is to know
about every character so I try to keep
my opinions on these sort of topics with
balance as light as possible and yeah
that's pretty much everything that I
would like to see in year 4 season 2 it
seems like a lot of stuff but most of
the stuff we already pretty much have
there's just going to be different
versions of it like we're obviously
getting a new character we're obviously
getting a battle pass we're definitely
gonna get executions and I'm pretty sure
we're gonna get armor I'm think about
pretty much everything I've mentioned in
this video is like 100% confirmed to
actually be a thing it's just the small
changes in what is actually going to be
in it is stuff that I can of course
predict well one last thing I want to
say before we kind of ended here is that
I actually plan on doing a video in the
future of your own opinions instead of
just mine we're gonna dedicate an entire
video just like this to your opinions on
what you would like for the new year for
season 2 I plan on doing this in a
couple weeks or so so in the comments
leave that stuff down below this could
be stuff or anything ideas thoughts
whatever you have heroes reworks battle
pass maps if it's a realistic idea you
can add that to if it's super
unrealistic you want flaming swords so
do I add that in the comment too I'll
take any single option and I will pick
some of the best to show off in the
video yeah guys that's going to be the
end of the bait today hopefully you guys
did enjoy it as always like the V if you
do enjoy subscribe if you're new I cover
the informational site a foreigner that
being the balance changes the hero
updates the patch notes and the leaks if
you want to be kept of today with
everything happened within the war
before honor I never miss out on an
update def we stay subscribe the channel
the guys take care have a great Easter
day and peace out I'll see in the next
video
[Music]
you